hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice puzzle I uh found yesterday while
browsing Twitter I know it's called X
now but browsing X just sounds dirty so
I'm going to call it I'm going to
continue to call it Twitter and uh it's
a mate in two supposedly by a famous
chess Rider and master anat matsukevich
although I don't know if that is true uh
fed CEO Emil suski posted it on his um
Twitter feed and it's a very nice mate
in two for white uh and it's it's not
your usual puzzle usually you when you
see a puzzle made in two you see the
where the king is and you're you know
approximately what you are supposed to
be looking at but here uh you have no
idea what you're supposed to be looking
at and it's just very abstract of course
the position can never happen in an
actual chess game and uh you know just
to trick you additionally I decided to
use the quote by uh by the legend
franois Andre danan filor the pawns are
the soul of the game as there are no
Pawns in this puzzle but yeah it's white
to made in two uh feel feel free to
pause the video and then we are going to
discuss uh if you were successful or not
or or maybe you need my help uh so have
at it couple of
seconds uh so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being a
true master of chaos and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show I
will now show it maybe you don't want me
to show it to you and you want to pause
it further or you want to maybe uh you
know just save it for later you can
check it out in a week in a month in a
year uh I don't want to spoil it for you
so you know be prepared I will now show
you the move uh and the move no first
I'm going to show you how how to well
maybe how to get to the move if you are
solving this uh uh weird construct so
the black king is here and you have to
deliver Checkmate in two moves uh what's
the easiest way to do this well we have
to check our surroundings so easiest way
would be to uh play Queen captures on A4
or to play Rook captures on A6 but
that's not really something that's
possible the bishop and queen are
guarding the Knight here and this Knight
does not the queen does not have any
support to capture on A4 but if that
were to change it would be very good on
the other hand uh we also have to check
does the king have uh has any Escape
squares the queen covers this Square the
bishop covers the B5 square and the
Knight covers the B6 Square so the king
if checked the will get checkmated now
Knight to B7 check would also be
Checkmate if the bishop wasn't covering
this square and Knight to C6 check would
also be Checkmate since we've already
checked that the black king has no
squares if the queen was not covering
the C6 square and like we said the White
Queen could deliver Checkmate if the
Knight was attacked at least one more
time so combining those three ideas we
easily find our move and that is Rook to
G4 uh Rook to G4
uh combines all of these three ideas as
it introduces another attacker to the A4
Knight and once you move the Rook uh of
course it can be captured by the bishop
but we know that if we move the bishop
we no longer control B7 and Bishop
captures here would result in Knight to
B7 Checkmate on the other hand if you
just uh looked for a move that you uh
you know triy to interpose The Rook try
to put something in between the rook and
the Knight there isn't anything uh
matsukevich if he did uh make this
construct made sure that no Bishops were
able to to go to the fourth Rank and the
only piece that is able uh to block The
Rook is the queen but now if you move
the Queen H yes of course now um the
Knight cannot be captured but you are no
longer covering that C6 Square so Knight
to C6 again will be a very nice
Checkmate so that's the idea Rook to G4
Bishop uh cannot move Queen cannot move
and if you do any other move and there's
nothing to to try and contest The Rook
uh just uh Queen captures on A4 will be
Checkmate uh so yeah that's the puzzle
hope you guys enjoyed it uh as I don't
know who actually constructed it I used
myself and Mr hoodi guy to play the game
and I thought it was fair to let Mr
hoodi guy um uh Checkmate me and I'm not
wearing the hoodie for this video as I'm
also in the video so it would be weird
if I was uh you know honoring the hoodie
guy while being myself in the video as
well uh but you know as as usual I'm
hoping you guys are were wearing a
hoodie for this one yeah very nicely
done very nice uh very nice puzzle by by
mukovic if he did make this and yeah
very nice post by Emil suski I was very
happy when when I saw this one haven't
seen it before I have seen similar ones
but not not quite this one so yeah hope
you enjoyed it uh you know brighten
brighten the day for your friends and
family uh use it use it wisely and
that's pretty much it I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to Caroline a
and I would like to thank Anna panovich
Robert kefir Welsh fan and Frank PL for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and do check out our app first link in
the description below uh see you
soon